c'est le scandale qui a fait parlé ce
week-end et qui sur les réseaux sociaux
a lancé un débat certains établissements
scolaires cacherait aux parents les cas
d'élèves et ont été testés positifs au
cours d'un virus
on a énormément d'écoles qui était
pendant plusieurs jours à ne pas savoir
quoi faire alors fait savait qu'il y
avait des cas confirmés dans un tweet
publié hier benjamin castaldi s'indigne
de cette gestion calamiteuse et des
mensonges par omission de la part de
l'école le lycée pasteur de neuilly sur
seine informe pas les parents que 13,4
peuvent ils ont été déclarés en première
l'animateur renchéri en expliquant que
cette dissimulation d'informations à des
conséquences graves sur sa vie et
pourrait même être carrément dangereux
résultat moi ma femme et mes quatre
enfants dont un bébé de cinq mois sont
qu'à contacter mon fils est en positif
depuis hier un message auquel de
nombreux internautes ont répondu en
allant dans le sens de benjamin castaldi
et français qui témoigne de pratiques
similaires dans les établissements
scolaires dans lesquelles leurs enfants
sont scolarisés
alors des écoles masquerait les cas
positifs à la commune un scandale alors
c'est vrai que beaucoup beaucoup de gens
parlent alors juste il ya benjamin
castaldi qui le dit le chiffre était
sorti avant sinon je ne l'aurais jamais
donné c'est vrai qu'ils étaient déjà
sortis au public dont benjamin
il a juste dreux relayer des infos qui
était en public c'est pas lui qui a
révélé les salaires des stars de the
voice bien entendu on met nicolas guiet
requête avec nous prof de français dans
un collège parisien merci nicolas d'être
là bonjour m'a beaucoup aidé à l'air
sympathique comme profanes général
nicolas tu pas kiffer envers les dires
de vous êtes prof de français dans
quelle classe 4e qu'elle est un chargé
de cours à l'iut de saut le semblant de
retour à l'école protect toi vous avez
des cas positifs dans le système
scolaire
vous allez nous dire ce que ce que vous
avez comme info il si vrai que ça c'est
incroyable gilles verdez qu'est-ce qui
se passe alors on a vraiment
l'impression que le ministère veut
minimiser les problèmes et que et à
queue en ce moment 64 établissements
fermés 7 au 22 janvier sur 61 mille 500
en france
pourquoi parce que le ministère ne veut
pas que les écoles ferment monsieur
blanc caire redoutent sa plus que tout
et donc ils maintiennent des
établissements ouverts jusqu'à ce que
les parents au bout d'un moment 10 mais
c'est impossible ya des cas positifs
dans ces cas là la préfecture et
seulement quand les parents alertent la
préfecture prend la mesure du problème
et va fermer d'abord des classes puis
des établissements donc c'est caché il y
aurait beaucoup de contamination dans
les cantines personne n'agit et c'est
vrai que c'est en train de monter
grandement les par 11 2
vraiment moi je suis pour le maintien de
la couverture des écoles c'est vrai mais
là les parents sont en train de se dire
est ce que je dois laisser mon enfant à
licola glières croix de français dans un
collège parisien on n'arrivait pas
décaissés c'est vrai tout ce que dit ce
qu'il ya des cas positifs qui sont
cachés dans les colonnes armées depuis
septembre mois c'est n'importe quoi
monsieur blanc car mon à longueur de
temps il ya santé publique france vous
connaissez tous est un organisme public
je sais pas du tout une officine
d'islamo gauche histoire voilà comment
j'ai redit il 10 8 à 9% de quart chez
les élèves
la commission bancaire 0,3 très étonnant
et ils assènent ils continuent dans les
établissements scolaires on est à 40
centimètres les uns de ces propos
n'engagent que nicolas c'est lui qui
voit la blessure qui l'a révélé mes
collègues et les stylos rouges que je
représente aujourd'hui aussi alors lui
sinon on m'a rappelé que série c'est un
groupe d'enseignants nés après pas de
vague en décembre 2018 qui luttent pour
salaire moyen respect notre devise pour
être entendue écoutée mieux payés mieux
considéré donc vous pensez que alors
vous pensez à prendre bien sûr au pour
digérer pour cacher des cas de kobe pour
ne pas fermer les écoles à mais
complètement monsieur blanc caire ne
veut pas que les écoles ferment
nous ne voulons pas non plus depuis le
mois de juin nous demandons je demande
partout je clame je crie je pleure pas
trop je demande à ce que les
établissements soient nus en 2000 groupe
collèges lycées écoles primaires pour
empêcher la fermeture pour l'éviter mais
en gros que tout le monde prenne sa part
fasse sa part fait son effort les
parents aussi et qu'ils acceptent de se
dire qu'un jour sur deux peut-être pour
éviter la fermeture pour éviter que des
gens ne meurent pour éviter que des gens
se retrouvent au real je vais prendre je
vais faire un effort et ma petite
réunion zoom mais je peux la faire avec
mon enfant un jour sur deux à la maison
non non on n'a pas savoir déjà allé
demander quelle explication il pouvait
trouver à ça je veux dire qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire dans ces cas là mais la
réalité que de nombreux parents il ne
veut pas ne peuvent pas s'occuper des
enfants toute la journée
le veulent pas beaucoup
pas aussi n'a pas des noms mais c'est
très calme très compliqué quand vous
travaillez à prix cassés au fait de vos
enfants ou est ce qu'ils vont manger on
parlait de canteen tout à l'heure c'est
très compliqué alors je sais que c'est
pas la honte à tout le monde il suffit
d'écouter il ya huit jours sur france
info un cadre d'entreprise qui expliqué
qu'ils n'avaient pas envie d'être en
télétravail qui boit mais qu'il avait
bondi de clients les paramètres boulot
alors qu'à jerez les pêches est lui
vraiment vous êtes isolé mais ça c'est
un énorme barbe la généralité lui les
sur le terrain donc y voit bien des gens
qui sont parfois au chômage et qui
emmène quand même leurs enfants à
l'école qui veulent pas garder l'enfant
lui la voix la réalité et mais aussi il
faut pas dire un jour sur deux il ya des
gens c'est pas possible en jambes sur
deux il ya des gens c'est le travail
cinq jours sur 7 des mêmes six jours sur
sept et même sept jours sur sept fois
sur le scandale de l'école moi je suis
je suis sûr à 100% j'ai des cars mois
autour de moi parce que j'ai autour de
moi j'ai des as mg des institutrices
j'ai plein de gens qu'est ce qu'ils me
disent les asem sont pas protégés
l'industrie sont pas protégés les msf
sont venus à vous irez faire ce qu on
ferme à vous classe sur 18
alors évidemment l'école elle n'est pas
fermée mais quand vous avez 12 classes
qui sont fermés sur 18 s'est quasi
l'école qui est fermé monsieur blanc
caire qui avait dit le 6 novembre 2020
on va faire des tests salivaires dans
toutes les écoles je me suis renseigné
du côté de vermont dont le 27 je suis me
renseigner du côté donné dans 95
colombes des argenteuillais nous a dit
je trace je me suis renseigné de huet
devant six ou sept écoles yao crainte
est ce qui est fait et les enfants et
les et les asem et les instits et les
animateurs ne sont pas testés je vous
dis évidemment leur intérêt c'est de
cacher n'est qu'à parce que si tu
révèles l'écart moment donné va falloir
fermer les écoles stéphane tapis oui
bonsoir
alors moi j'ai reçu un mail
ce soir me prévenant qu'à partir de
demain ma fille était à l'école à la
maison puisqu'il y avait des cas en
terminale es en sixième à l'étang 6e et
du coup ils fermions comment du var est
en danger il ya des cas du variant
caezar notamment anglais alors et donc
ils ont fermé toute l'école excepté les
petites sections d'accord donc ça c'est
donc là y'a pas très bien fait je vois
pas en quoi plantaire n'intervient enfin
bloqué mais pas dans toutes les écoles
le nom c'est le chef d'établissement
normalement qui doit se signaler les cas
qui doit faire la décision
vraiment je vous ai sûr je suis pas du
genre à les défendre en principe mais il
fait ce qu'il peut avec l'apparition du
ministère du rectorat des inspecteurs
qui lui disent naissent ouvert laisse
ouvert dans ces revenir les profs qu'à
contacter ou malade comment il ya des
cas le parisien on parle sud ouest en
parle france bleu on parle des profs
malades cas contacts donc son geste et
consorts savent selon vous alors faisons
venir des selon vous les directeurs
d'établissements ont des prérogatives
qui disent il faut laisser les hôtels
ouverts les écoles ouvertes coûte que
coûte
donc ils ont ils ajouté qu ils ont des
consignes comme et clairement il faut
les siens voilà je vais fermer les yeux
sur certains cas c'est ça un repas
ensemble dans la vie normale je mangeais
avec vous tranquillement
m nice avec plusieurs magazines docomo
gens semblent on a déclaré qu'un contact
direct si jamais l'un des deux l'un des
trois alco vide à l'école on peut être
on n'est pas déclaré qu'à contacter
pourquoi majid d'école pouvoirs magiques
monsieur blanc car c'est son sport là
c'est du moins la raison parce que c'est
pas c'est qu'on divise par exemple je
veux donner deux animateurs szavay 2 et
je vous ai deux as m
ça fait deux et je vais vous et 2 un
site on a six personnes là oui mais ils
vont dire non on n'a que deux animateurs
tels que l'instit et 2 assènent ils
divisent en fait donc pas que deux cas à
chaque fois mais faut pas diviser c'est
la rs qui vient au dessus au dessus de
ceux des enseignants même si la
directrice a dit a dit une chose la rs10
noé la mairie dinan derrière encore mais
si
on a on a aujourd'hui un souci de
transparence et à quelques mois quand
des gens mouraient d'autre chose que du
coup vides ont gonflé les chiffres et on
disait que c'était le co lead et
aujourd'hui on essaye de minimiser pour
la c dès l'école ouvert alors qu'à côté
de ça y est les restaurants qui sont
fermées alors qu'on pourrait très bien
faire des tests pour que les gens
puissent aller manger s'ils sont des
pizzas sur tf1 pouvait pas dire delphine
qu'on a bien un souci est qu'on a dit
qu'il avait des gens qui mouraient dos
du côté alors que c'était autre chose ça
joue les bons gens qui bossent à jour là
le cousin d'une cousine 6 il a des gens
qui me voient la ccnb qui fait jour où
tu l'a reçue moi je suis reviendra chez
un peu d'accord moi je vous entends
alors effectivement à vous entendre on
nous ment globalement on nous manipule
et en plus on nous met en danger
c'est à dire contre angers nos enfants
et on met les parents dans la société
comment on peut expliquer qu'à six
personnes ont extrait avec un masque on
pourrait se mettre en danger
mais à 40 30 35 40 par classe dans des
classes fermées y aurait aucune
contamination possible c'est absurde ici
à l'accusé la raison des accusations
utilisation trop grave pour être portés
sans qu'elles soient étayés par autre
chose que des cas particuliers
voilà parce que moi j'ai justement pas
d'objets tous à nous citer ce sont des
cas particuliers a pas une volonté de
manipulation au sommet de l'ordre parce
que ça c'est grave mais beaucoup d'une
volonté de ne pas fermer les écoles
coûte que coûte c'est ça l'idée mais les
nôtres parce que nombreux de parents ne
veulent pas les garder c'est un fait
nous brut par an ne veulent pas prendre
le risque de deux pouvoirs - bien
travaillé chez eux je longtemps je le
comprends c'est [ __ ] pour qui la rend
tout à fait mais moi j'étais mais pas au
rayon vaison et ç'a toujours été
exemplaire ça fait un an que je reçois
des mails régulièrement de chefs d'état
de m
j'ai aussi bien du privé à la part du
public à la maison de la clape est celle
de tout un tas mais ça dépend de toi ce
moment la maison de l'art et du calme et
tu peux pas globaliser en disant que
globalement il cherche absolument en
place sur nos enfants ne vont pas je
n'ai jamais dit ça mais vous diront on
monte le fait qu'il y en a ce qu'il faut
pour que le virus ne se répande pas les
variants ne se répande pas on n'est pas
protégé isole les enfants des cas des
cas contacts on les revoit la maison à
chacun on les teste à chaque fois non
excusez-moi remâche et des collations
première chose à ajouter
oui le fait que monsieur blon clermont à
longueur de temps quand il dit qu'on est
protégé est-ce que vous rendez compte
que ce ministre a expliqué vos enfants
et les
enseignants sont plus à l'abri à l'école
qu'à la maison enfin c'est du délire
comment on peut dire ça avec un virus il
ya des chiffres le nombre de classes
fermées a doublé en seulement une
semaine
on est passé de donkey fanon s'ils n'ont
pas ce sont des bras cassés
ils font tout et derniers mois quand ils
n'ont plus le choix
concrètement c'est ce qui se passe il ya
86 % non à 14% voyez les lions parce que
c'est un scandale et y croire a
apparemment
on